I'm Jospeh and I work for work on
research in Algrim R&D and they talk
about the new feature in the short work
enjoy
I'm going to talk about them what you
enjoy making - on 12 or the
communication well I will try to kind of
condense it I've been a lot of change
lot of improvement throughout the whole
framework of geometry show you what you
can probably notice so we talked about
the improvement essentially in the
usability of ocean allottee essentially
I will talk about the new future sea and
probably also give you a general idea of
the direction where we are going with
geometry okay
so let's jump in term of improvement
they have been a lot of improvement
behind the scene essentially we were
beautiful
pretty much part of the whole framework
in geometry to be able to accommodate
lot of requests from user functionality
so to make a kind of probe engineer it
on make it 3d - to support more features
but one thing I would like to
essentially talk about is what we did
for boolean operation so most of you for
one boolean operation and you know quite
useful for modeling as such so what we
try to do is to put the boolean
operation in bash on to try to put a
boolean operation in this coming
well so we're an aberration in bhishan
twelve and one of the key team we try to
do is sensuality kg actually it does
apply to other odd up you know functions
in version 12 is that we try to preserve
the type so if you give us mesh page on
we try to return your mesh when John if
you give us formula away John we try to
return your formula region so we stay in
that class of family but that also means
that some operation are not
mathematically correct right so if you
take a message on which is closed and
you do a difference you will probably
get an open set essentially in that case
we give you you know do the closure of
that set but we know that is what kind
of you you know user respect when you do
modeling when you manipulate image by
John but if you take an implicit wait
John and then you do a difference you
probably get another and pitch it to a
John where you can actually which will
probably open because you cannot have a
present so that's one of the key thing
we try to do behind the scenes so I will
just give you some basic example plus we
have which are probably talk later about
polyhedron which is a new basic
primitive you're introducing so we also
using it because it's one way to
actually represent cells basic cells and
it allows to give computation so in
version 11 I believe if you do that
operation we get a bond that image way
John but now you can get actually know a
polyhedron a nicer presentation can
actually manipulate it so we you know we
continue to improve boolean operations
and this kind of show you actually the
improvement I think this was region
intersections so our goal is actually to
reach you know a hundred percent in type
of benchmarks so this is the random set
up I think 400
HDL file which we download it and we try
to see you know how good we are doing
from 70 percent you are number 95
percent but we need to give that account
right beside and boolean operation are
pretty much are really complicated
actually at first it seems to be that
easy but we we need behind we seem to be
able to recognize the structure the
object you give to us if the align we
need to have algorithm for line line
intersection to have
quite efficiency but if they are polygon
polygon polygon intersection triangle
triangle detection but also we need to
you know if you give us an exact input
we need to return your exact output so
we need to have those algorithm if you
give us approximate machining you know
machine number we need to attain your
machine number so we need to build all
that behind the scene so that's probably
one of the function will keep improving
every release so we are kind of working
on that
so I'm asking just patient but we'll get
there so the next thing is essentially
discretization so in the common version
actually we improve our discretization
for nonlinear primitive spline B splines
Q Bar so she will start to work now
so this is this is a basic example of a
B spline you generate it you can
discretize it on a you get a nice wedge
on there so that's also mean for example
exporting your file in HDL will
automatically work if you want to do 3d
printing such because we can also kind
of generate them what also we hope in
the future like you probably noticed our
discritization 20 dozen handle Musa
primitive so if you you know you take
you know a bunch of spline with balls
you know you probably cannot combine
them to return you a nice mesh way job
because obviously that require boolean
operation so as soon as we have a you
know better boolean operation most
tables one descritization also be
improved is graphic they've been also so
improvement in discretize agent and we
hope that boolean operation also will
improve the discretized wage on in that
same direction we'll be able to discuss
implicit wage on and give you shut you
know edges on all those nice features so
the next thing which is likely who later
at it you know cylindrical decomposition
I believe Adam can be talk a little bit
more about it later in the talk you know
MPC try John essentially for civil
operation high you know rely on card
essentially so what we can do here
essentially become twitch led by
decomposition give you the boundary of
the set the closure the interior so this
is a pillow a basic inequality polygon
you know polynomial inequality you can
ask the boundary it will give you the
boundary if you plot it or you can
actually ask the connected component so
it's what actually behind you seen for
implicit region when you give you know
polynomial equality or inequality for
and we hope that as we move forward we
are going to actually introduce more
force on topological operation for
geometry in general so one other
improvement actually I put here one of
the improvement is on our integral
measure so we introduced with bacteria
which was highly demanded because people
wanted to compute the area of football
and we usually just come back and tell
you that's not possible
it's kind of hard computing we're going
to produce surface area now
which actually does that and it will
change your white value and you'll
actually work pretty nice when possible
so here you have intersection of two
balls and you can compute the surface
area well it takes some time but you
know computer surface area and what can
you do the exact value so also what we
did is we added more support for
assumptions in great condition for those
anti callamezzo so in this case for
example I can take this and please sit
with John and actually area you return
you we happy you know it's a non
constant wage on it have a parameter a
generate condition you were trying to
condition control all you can give an
assumption which is false in this case
you will tell you well not PC false but
the region is happening so you can do
stamboli competition on top of our
region pretty nicely now so we support a
sum so
and such but also what we did is that we
added working precision precision goal
and all the numeric operation
essentially to provide a new workflow so
what we notice in some case is that if
you give a lady probably this will not
work for this one but if you give you
know a complicated and PC to a job let's
suppose cosine so if you try to compute
this right behind the scene we try to
first find the exact output in most of
the case you'll probably fail right
because this patient get really
complicated I mean you can give me a bit
too implicit wager so what we try to do
essentially to see that can we have a
numerical method to actually do that
most of this identical Mito so you can
call probably you know reform lated
transfer equal to any take wait so we
can generate you a message and give you
an approximate value so that's kind of
the idea but working places on precision
goal behind so in most of the cases be
able to actually get an approximate
value and if you want an exact and you
already wait for two days then you can
just set those parameters and we hope to
propagate all those you know parameter
domestic okay one of the requested
feature was to actually support empty
region full rage mesh region and bundle
image region has copy primitive so we
added it's essentially you can generate
a mesh like that and use it in graphics
the graphic primitive you can use
opacity on all the stuff you want so
that give you the flexibility for
example to add texture which we don't
yet have for meshes come and pollute all
that already
so other future actually other
improvement on transformer agent so as I
said before we try to stay in the class
when we do operation so here you take it
a try on you can give you a function and
then it can give you the result so
essentially what we did behind the scene
is that we look at your force on like in
this case this is a linear force on this
is it
they tried one is the linear object we
know that you know the mapping will be
always linear and then we can actually
analyze the structure the function on
the object onto the operation and we do
the same office speaking for mesh we
assume if you use mesh that means you
want to get a do any mesh object right
so in this case the force on which is
nonlinear we take it we transform it to
mesh and try to actually find the white
cell structure close enough to the
output and then we return you a mesh
object at the end so we try to remain in
that class of you know mesh mesh all you
can't do this simple implicit way John
so down here having mesh an implicit way
John I can't compute inverse quite
easily and I get E and piss it away Joe
so we kind of mix the numerix and
Bullock and all this technique all at
once but try to remain in the same class
so I kind of stop here because you know
I can spend the whole day kind of
talking about the improvement we shall
be working for a while but essentially
we improved the selection of algorithms
so I will switch between the different
algorithm you have and precision and
exactness we support you know material
presentation so you give us a triangle
you give us an edge to edge on we
understand that they offer the same
object because you can represent it
triangle has a mesh object and then we
right you pick the white algorithm to do
a computation and return you a triangle
at the end or edge on depending on how
you give the input so we need to make
all those decision behind the scene
and also we do a lot of canonicalization
so we they take basic arrow like if you
take a cube oh wait in our specification
you have to give the lower bound the
lope in lowest point on the Ohio corner
but most on people's you know you can
get confuse and give the opposite
there's a tiny or we can correct so we
detect that we're here adjusted
automatically and then everything works
as I say support of assumptions in red
condition to the whole system and
obviously performance improvement will
always try to be fast and give you the
best result possible and there is more
but anyway this kind of briefly what we
have been doing so let's see what's new
okay
I will start by with angle so what we
did in version 12 is that going to
reduce planner angle to compute angles
so you can compute counterclockwise or
clockwise based on the specification so
P is your point and q1 and to 2028 you
can just use that or you can use these
twin to say clockwise or
counterclockwise you can pick the angle
on both side and obviously work with
symbolic value to when possible on
generate condition and assumption to and
also one specification which was
requested is you know inform of it
Khurana essentially they was to enter
your angle Phi angle you can see you
enter your angle the exterior angle or
the full angle depending of which type
of undal you want
so plan our angle is simple you can
generalize up a plan angle into way in
3d you can define it as if there is an
angle between two planes so here you
give the to point you know p1 and p2 and
then the two vector we define your
planes or you can actually use explicit
to our half plane to define it and then
you get hopefully speaking the right
angle so we can also compute all that
nicely
and it's also support symbolic values
the second generalization of plan angle
of the idle angle Zoey I will jump this
example due to the time the
synchronization is solid angles right so
essentially solid angle is an angle at
the point P span by set or vector or is
an angle sub seen by an object roughly
speaking so currently we can actually
compute solid angles vector which is
essentially if you look at the 3d case
is essentially the measure of the
surface area of the intersection of the
cone from that point we do a ball so all
these four sites are quite useful
depending of what you are doing so we
have planner angle the Hydra Langille or
solid angle and solid angle with
principle working nd okay I was just
kind of just slightly talk about oh just
say that you know we have introduced
that entity geometry in 12 and I've been
using a lot of the existing
functionality there will be a talk later
on actually I believe at 3:00 3:30 about
that stick around and look at that so
essential is Murray kind of different
overhand in every single instance of
turin ascension on such and as you see
it Rancho kind of belong to new
functionality about angles on such okay
well the key feature in 12 is polygons
actually that's not true I do have
polygons see what you actually did
invest on 12 is that we introduced
polygons with armed polygons with holes
are mostly angles but polygons with
holes so before our polygon essentially
you define them with you know a set of
point I'll coordinate the set of
coordinate there you can get the polygon
I don't under
so the first thing you notice is that
you know we introduced a tab setting for
polygon and the typesetting contained a
number of point on the bond and you can
actually analyze it efficiently so
that's the easy part that's what we had
before and one key to the one key thing
to remember is that the server
definition of polygon most of the people
are not used to it
in our definition in our documentation
actually does the main line here one
line we use essentially the click
hosting intersection the number of odd
or even line of intersection especially
when you are polygons have intersection
self intersections so now what we did in
12 is that we introduced polygons with
holes so you can also quite similar to
what we had before I'll give a set of
point and after that give a list of
holes as a list of point so in this case
I define that I have my list of points
so that's kind of defined auto boundary
and as a whole the inner boundary and
then you can notice that this object I
define is actually essentially the same
I had before here you have you define it
by you know a set of line intersection
to the right closing and as I said
before what we do behind we seem to do
geometries that we actually look at
those representation even though they
are different you understand that they
are the same and we can do the
computation we turn you to Coit also so
these out that framework behind the
scene we kind of go to me to actually
analyze that so that's one form of the
polygon we extended so you can use a
whole to define it
well that was a simple the same place
for presentation we found the easiest
one to type is more about author
boundary you associated to the inner
boundary so we went that way later on
Jabbar will probably talk a little bit
more about polygons and we can probably
discuss a little bit more about that
what we don't issue so the next
representation we have its polygon which
is awfully similar to the kaepa complex
you can give a set of point and then the
data so these are the coordinate and
then you have a list so it's roughly
that graphic complex you are used to a
presentation and this is quite useful
for the next object I'm going to talk
about which is polyhedron as you can
imagine polyhedron is a bunch of faces
which are coming from polygons so you
don't want to duplicate point or such so
this representation or copy that graphic
complex form allow you to actually have
a compatible annotation we handle it
correctly so there is no restriction the
outer polygons the inner polygons can
all be surf intersecting we want
depending on your definition of a
deferred if initially they were closing
but we do that correctly so it's all
that complicating behind-the-scene we
need to actually ambiguous on solve
no essentially so like in this case
right you can have a self closing here
and self course in there so you know in
the same place where you just say what
what we do is that we can only collide
this we find another boundary an inner
boundary and we do the same for all the
holes outer boundary inner boundary and
then we do a difference origin
difference for them but we need to do
that efficiently that if you give us ten
million of them will hold it and Japan
will talk about the general body
canonicalization of polygons so you can
actually have happy fortune conical
polygons you type it and it actually
give you that form in a country you do
canonical form we use internally
actually so I would go really fast we
don't have much time so there is a lot
of function related to polygons as I say
canonicalization polygons coordinate in
a polygon you have course in polygon
winding polygons depending on the
definition before defined some time the
diffusion based on the winding number so
it give us two polygons we can figure
that out
we have a new random generator for
polygon convex polygon sample and such
and also we can do decomposition polygon
based on you know come you know convex
sample or such I will just continue
really fast on these so the next object
we introduced is essentially well I'll
also ban you know bypass the
optimization I think you talked earlier
about all the improvement the front end
also did a lot of improvement to support
polygons with holes as well as be it's
very fast found way so the next object
introduces polyhedra for yet one sorry
so it's half you have the same centers
as polygons but now you have a list of
coordinate so this I mean a list of
polygons so this is an example
he's also Puerto soap you know you can
have voice you can have Colonel and all
the fancy things so if you just have the
you know the whole idea of polygon in
mind for the other one is kind of
roughly the same generalization you can
also specify with hole with the same
hole or such so what we try to do is to
maintain that same form and that same
structure so that's kind of natural to
you too
so just you know bypass all that and
with a couple of second 1/2 so our
planet essentially to keep improving
geometry which way John unfortunately
actually we are going to do it
unfortunately request multiple mesh
region and we hope to add new primitive
or support of nonlinear primitive you
know spline and herb and so on pull it
up supporting n dimension and also do
vertical an application you know we did
3d printing we do it game engine which
are reality more will be coming well
kind of show our personality in geometry
and well if you want to know more about
polygons and pull head-on and all the
nice thing we have well stick around
jibba jibba Manion we talk right now
about all that and probably at around
3:30 there's also talk about planar
geometry
[Applause]